13 years into the zombie apocalypse The
Walking Dead is a complicated Mythos and
a twisted chronology even before you add
in spin-offs like Fear The Walking Dead
and Walking Dead World Beyond looking to
piece it all together here's all you
need to know
even after more than a decade on the air
and multiple spin-off shows The Walking
Dead still hasn't revealed the true
origin of the Wildfire virus that
brought about the zombie apocalypse in
the pronouncements episode of Walking
Dead Season 1 CDC scientist Dr Jano
reveals that the virus has been
spreading worldwide for at least 190
days before communication lines went
down French scientists broadcast that
they believed they were close to
developing a cure but no one knew what
the virus had originated it could be
microbial viral parasitic fungal or the
wrath of God
there's that
Dr Jenna learns for his research that
the virus had gone Airborne in the
season one finale ets19 he tells Rick
that everyone is infected no matter how
they die all of them will rise again as
Walkers the discovery goes a long way
towards explaining how the virus toppled
societies around the world so quickly
Rick Grimes spends roughly the first two
months of the outbreak in a coma when he
wakes up in the hospital Society has
entirely collapsed he's only alive
because Shane barricaded his hospital
room before helping Laurie and Carl get
out of town Rick miss the immediate's
aftermath of the outbreak but he quickly
gets up to speed with what went down in
2015 Fear The Walking Dead decided to
explore the early days of reckon the
fans miss when Walking Dead first aired
in 2010 the spin-off opens just as the
Wildfire virus is beginning to infect
people in the United States at first
most people don't understand anything
about what's going on and No One
Believes Nick Clark when he tells them
his zombified girlfriend was eating
people fear the Walking Dead spends much
of its first three seasons catching up
to the moment when Rex Journey Begins
along the way the show reveals that
Society more or less collapsed within
three weeks of the Wildfire outbreak in
the episode Cobalts it's revealed that
the military plans to evacuate the LA
Basin and bomb the area to kill the
infected in season two's We All Fall
Down the plan is scaled up and all the
major coastal cities in North America
are destroyed but it's not enough to
stop the walkers
The Walking Dead Season 1 follows Rick
Grimes and his group into the Atlanta
area as he tries to find his family and
the group tries to find help at the CDC
after the CDC explodes Rick and his crew
are on the road until they cross paths
with herschel's family when Sophia gets
lost and Carl gets shot while season two
feels like it lasts a decade it really
spans just a few weeks the groove spends
a first winch of the Apocalypse back on
the road until they find the prison and
decide to make a new home for themselves
and the soil is good we could plant some
seed grow some tomatoes cucumbers
soybeans
in season three they come face to face
with the governor a conflict with
Woodbury Burns itself out after a few
months but along the way Rick loses his
wife Laurie in childbirth and Daryl's
brother Merle betrays the governor at
the expense of his own life people are
gonna die
I'm gonna die mom
there's no way you can ever be ready for
three concludes about a year after Rick
got shot at the beginning of the
outbreak
later seasons of The Walking Dead Leap
Forward in time sometimes even within a
single season it can be easy to forget
that there were times when the series
crept along at a snail's pace without
sacrificing any of his entertainment
value season 4 takes place over less
than two weeks but they might be the
hardest weeks Rick's group ever has to
face the Story begins about six months
after the end of season three the people
of Woodbury have moved into the prison a
governing Council has been formed and
Rick Grimes has decided to take her
backseat to the action and work on
farming with Carl then a virus of the
more traditional variety decimates the
group after everything
I was just gonna take it out by a
glorified cold
they lose the majority of their people
and just when they're really beginning
to recover the governor returns and
permanently destroys the home they've
built for the back half of the season
the group is separated and on the road
Glenn meets Abraham Eugene and Rosita
and they help reunite him with Maggie I
thought we were looking for Glenn if he
saw one of these he would go looking for
me looking for him
Daryl and Beth travel together until
she's taken by officers from Grady
Memorial Hospital everyone follows signs
from a serious Community called Terminus
and they all finally meet back in a
train car after becoming prisoners of
the community
unfortunately for the heroes of The
Walking Dead their hardships don't get
easier during season five Terminus as it
turns out as a community of cannibals
and the group is forced to fight their
way out eventually almost everyone is
back together and hiding out in
Gabriel's Church but Beth is still
trapped inside Grady Memorial hospital
with Noah and the others that offers a
dorm refuses to let leave we're all
gonna die and you let this happen for
nothing
the season six episode he is not here
reveals that around this time Morgan who
originally helped Rick after he got out
of his coma is living with a man named
Eastman and learning how to define
himself in the new world and heal from
his violent past when Eastman dies
Morgan begins traveling in the direction
of Rick's group though he doesn't know
it at the time meanwhile reckon the
others lose Beth in a confrontation with
Dawn at the hospital with nothing left
for them in Georgia the group decides to
head north towards DC where Noah's
family had lived inside a gated
community by the time they arrive at
Noah's home the entire Community has
been overrun by Walkers and Noah's
family is dead disheartened and running
low on supplies the group decides to
continue on to DC proper but along the
way they're approached by Aaron a
recruiter from Alexandria and invited
into his community not long after Rick's
group arrives Morgan also finds his way
to Alexandria and they all begin working
together to keep their new home safe
Rick and his friends managed to help
Alexandria survive a herd of zombies and
an attack from a gang known as The
Wolves but the piece that follows
doesn't last long the saviors are first
introduced in season six when Rick and
the others learn that they've been
extorting supplies from the hilltop
Community they're a scattered
confrontations with the saviors
throughout the season but the conflict
reaches ahead in the finale in the
season 7 premiere the day will come when
you won't be Negan reveals himself as
the leader of the saviors brutally
murders Glennon Abraham and takes
control of Alexandria oh look at there
taking it like a champ
the war with the Savior stretches
through the entirety of season seven and
eight but Rick's group doesn't spend
years under the savior's control instead
Alexandria unites forces with the other
communities and overpowers the saviors
in a little more than a month during
these Seasons we lose many beloved
characters including Sasha Williams and
devastatingly Carl Grimes Negan issaken
to Alexandria as a prisoner there's a
large time gap between the end of The
Walking Dead Season 8 and the beginning
of season 9 a little more than a year
passes as the communities adjust to
their new Cooperative way of life being
here
Behind These Walls again you just don't
feel right man
I'm better out there
Rick struggles to keep the communities
working together on a bridge project
that will make travel between them
easier the project is ultimately doomed
to fail pursued by a massive herd of
zombies Rick is forced to sacrifice
himself and blow up the bridge in order
to save his people in Rick's final
episode what comes after we see that
he's been airlifted away in a helicopter
manned by unknown forces but all of his
friends believe he's dead the next
episode jumps six years into the future
Juliet is now about as old as Carl was
when the series began and the
communities have entirely pulled away
from each other
The Walking Dead weld Beyond as planned
as a two-season spin-off focused on a
generation of kids who are coming of age
during the zombie apocalypse think we'll
need those
probably won't need them
we'll be behind the bear here
the first season aired in October 2020
and is set exactly 10 years after the
initial outbreak of the Wildfire virus
and that puts well Beyond in a span of
time between red crimes as apparent
death and what comes after and the
continuation of The Walking Dead Season
9 that begins in who are you now well
beyond is set in Nebraska and features a
new group of characters in The Walking
Dead Universe the Civic Republic
military is a pseudo-government
organization trying to bring peace and
order to the apocalypse they have plenty
of people and resources including
helicopters branded with the same logo
as a helicopter that Jadis called in to
rescue Rick what the CRM is really up to
and what they've done with Rick remains
a mystery but their presence and World
beyond the shows that the franchise is
interested in telling larger stories
about the world as a whole in the zombie
apocalypse
The Walking Dead takes its time
revealing what happened between reg
blowing up the bridge and the events of
who are you now at some point Michonne
realizes she's pregnant with Rick's
child and gives birth to RJ the
communities try for a while to continue
working together but Michonne eventually
decides that Alexandria will take an
isolationist approach to everyone else
in order to keep the community safe
Negan has remained in prison there for
more than seven years and formed a close
bond with Judith after he saves Judas
life in a blizzard he earns a reluctant
Place helping out in the Kingdom's
Community Carol moves to the kingdom
where she and Ezekiel raise Henry as her
own son Daryl spends most of the
in-between years living out in the woods
searching in vain for Rick's body is the
last time you ate
dog ate yesterday
he never finds it but he does bond with
a woman named Leah and her dog before
Leah goes missing and dog is left in
Daryl's care the reformed saviors joined
the various communities working for
survival but it's a Year's Dragon
everyone begins to realize that the
communities need to find a way to
cooperate once again
as the apocalypse approaches its 13th
year the Whisperer War erupts it's the
most violent and destructive conflict in
the history of The Walking Dead the
fight against Negan may have been more
emotionally impactful for some of the
characters on the show but the
whisperers take much more away from the
surviving communities most notably in
the fair Massacre near the end of season
nine the season concludes with Alpha
establishing new borders for the
communities and the kingdom finally
falling after years of dwindling
resources and structural disrepair the
storm seeds are communities at their
lowest points since the war of the
saviors and without the resources to
fight Alpha they abide by her rules for
the better half of a year in season 10
the communities finally work together to
resist Alpha and the fighting carries
them into the apocalypse's 13th year the
survivors defeat the whisperers with
help from a surprising Ally Negan burst
it costs them Hilltop and the walls that
surround Alexandria by the end of season
10 the communities are still alive but
their position is more precarious than
it has been in years
does the apocalypse stretches into year
13 The Walking Dead enters season 11.
Eugene Ezekiel yumiko and Princess whom
the former three met on their Journey
are all trying to enter a massively
resourceful Community called The
Commonwealth in the hopes that they'll
be able to get some assistance for
Alexandria and the people who were
displaced from the kingdom in Hilltop
Maggie has returned to Alexandria with
some new friends because their home was
destroyed by a group of violent
survivors who called themselves the
Reapers Maggie believes that was some
help she can reclaim that home and use
its resources to help Alexandria in The
Wider world of The Walking Dead there
are still plenty of unknowns but shonius
discovered Rick might be alive and she's
gone off on a journey to find him Morgan
is likely battling through a radiated
zombie somewhere in the American
southwest a CRM is still trying to
reform society and it looks as though
the Commonwealth is doing the same
everyone has faced an imaginable loss
but the world is busier and more
populated than it's been since before
the outbreak of the Wildfire virus the
only thing that's is that there's much
more Danger action and hopefully Triumph
to come we are
season of The Walking Dead aired in
three segments over the course of a year
the first third focuses on wrapping up
Maggie's struggles for the group that
destroyed her new home and forced her to
return to Alexandria the pack calls
themselves a Reapers and they're led by
a grim man who calls himself Pope the
pseudo-religious organization of the
Reapers sets them apart from anything
else our survivors have encountered
before and their fanaticism makes it
impossible to negotiate and enter their
conflict Maggie takes a group of
alexandrians including Gabriel Daryl and
Negan back to her old Camp believing
that together they can defeat the
Reapers and reclaim supplies that
Alexandria desperately needs as is
usually the case for the heroes on The
Walking Dead nothing goes as planned
traveling to Maggie's Camp means
traversing a walker-infested Subway
tunnel and some of the Survivors die
along the way I got a door open on the
forehead did you close it
ah Gage as soon as the group reaches
Maggie's Camp the Reaper's attack
scattering everyone and claiming lives
in the process in a surprising twist
Daryl realizes that Leah the woman he
had a relationship with in the season 10
episode find me is a member of the
Reapers he sees an opportunity to end
the conflict peacefully but that option
goes out the window when Maggie kills
more of Leah's people ultimately Daryl
kills Leah and everyone returns to
Alexandria with the supplies the
citizens of Alexandria may be going
through a rough patch but their problems
are fairly minor compared to what is
happening to the characters in fear The
Walking Dead in the wake of multiple
nuclear detonations Texas is an
irradiated Wasteland Morgan and his
friends are struggling just to survive
and that's without taking the
radioactive Walkers that now Patrol the
waste into account season 7 of Fear The
Walking Dead is largely centered on the
remnants of the Texas survivors falling
into conflict with each other strand has
taken control of a massive Tower and he
used as a horde of Walkers as a mode to
maintain his control don't do this
I won't make it out there I'm sorry
I'm not sorry
a dangerous group called The stalkers
lurks outside the tower robbing and
killing anyone they encounter as the
season progresses Morgan's efforts to
keep his friends alive get him rubbed up
in the search for something called Padre
an organization created pre-fall that
supposedly has all the resources anyone
might need to get some form of
civilization restarted eventually
strands control over the tower falls
apart and The Refuge there crumbles
Morgan and some of his companions find
their way to Louisiana where they have
the opportunity to go see Padre for
themselves unfortunately there are signs
that while it may have all the resources
rumors claim it's not exactly working in
the best interest of the
post-apocalyptic survivors We've Come To
Love
as Morgan contends with unimaginable
obstacles in Texas the survivors in
Alexandria are confronted with something
equally unimaginable a functional city
of 50 000 human beings in their efforts
to find new supplies that can keep
Alexandria afloat and survivors discover
the Commonwealth which promises to
deliver everything that the old world
had to offer the Commonwealth's promise
turns out to be all too true while
there's relative peace and abundance in
the settlement's walls there's also
rampant political corruption and a
brewing class war the settlement is led
by Pamela Milton and her second in
command Lance Hornsby Milton will do
anything to maintain her and her son's
status as Elite citizens even if it
means condemning the poorest
Commonwealth citizens to endless work in
labor camps Hornsby dreams of having
even more power and he begins exercising
an iron grip on the outside settlements
destroying Oceanside and transforming
Alexandria into a town-sized prison in
his pursuit of Milton's approval as soon
as the alexandrians get involved in the
Commonwealth they begin unearthing the
corruption and conspiracies hiding
underneath a settlement's surface that
puts some adults with the militants and
Hornsby but the alexandrians had never
been once to back down from a fight they
recognized the promise of the
Commonwealth and they believe that by
standing up to its evil leaders they can
form a society better than anything the
old world had to offer
the survivors of the Walking Dead have
survived countless battles believing
each one would prove to be the Turning
Point guaranteeing them peace and
happiness in the future this time they
may be right the alexandrians stand with
the people of the Commonwealth and
challenged the settlement's leadership
together the house Pamela Milton and
Lance Hornsby by the end of season 11
Ezekiel is the leader of a commonwealth
that is finally a true democracy working
for the betterment of its citizens The
Walking Dead may be over but its
Universe lives on and will only be
expanding in the future a spin-off
starring Jeffrey Dean Morgan and Lauren
Cohan will take Maggie and Negan to New
York City another spin-off will follow
Daryl Dixon to France and give viewers a
whole new perspective on the zombie
apocalypse Carol
yeah
you deserve a happy ending too most
exciting of all a spin-off focused on
Rick and Michonne will finally answer
questions that have been lingering in
fans Minds since Rick was dramatically
airlifted off The Walking Dead in season
9. there will still be Walkers to fight
and survivors to organize into something
like a cohesive Society but the new
focus of The Walking Dead franchise will
show viewers the apocalypse on a global
scale